Matthew McConaughey and remember they
starred in the 2014 drama interstellar
together well their new movie serenity
it is just as thrilling and we talked
about all of that but first you know I
had to get Anne's take on the recent
Oscar controversy can I ask you an
because you have you hosted the Oscars
before what do you think about all this
hoopla that's been made about trying to
lock down a hose look there's a lot of
different things to consider when
talking about when talking about it but
that being said I do just want to go on
record as saying I think the LGBTQ
community needs all the allies in the
world what's the toughest part though
about hosting the Oscars what's the most
challenging day major props to an who
can laugh off those Oscar host reviews
she's blonde and back with Matthew in
the noir thriller serenity I want you to
take him out on your boat and drop him
in the ocean to the Sharks I love that
we flipped the script here and we got
the skin shown on the male side this
time in this film actually showed a lot
I did no no that's good for box office
or bad back you don't ever use like a
devil that's you mean time and picked up
a life lesson from Matthew's wife
Camilla bring less stuff if you can I'm
trying to get to a place in my life
where I can go anywhere in the world for
any length of time with just two
carry-on
[Music]